pire les
[Musique]
franchement moi j'adore parce qu'il ya
plein de couleurs et c'est une fête
quand même très joyeuse et dubaï grâce à
ça et tout le monde se réunit fait la
fête en lançant des couleurs sur tout le
monde et en colorant quasiment tout le
monde
[Musique]
j'adore cette fête elle est très joyeuse
même tout - est venu avec même s'il
avait déjà terminé et je trouve que ça
met une bonne ambiance et on est beaux
après quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
les étourdis suis sûr de lui
[Rires]
[Musique]
ils
sont bien accueillis c'est vrai que
qu'ils ont une manière de fonctionner
c'est pas comme en france donc ça fait
plaisir c'est notre culture at il entre
à l'école
comme une hymne national enfin je sais
pas trop mais c'est vraiment comme les
militaires alors que nous en france on
fait pas ça on arrive on rentre dans les
classes et c'est différent il ya aussi
ce contact physique c'est vrai que on a
fait le moringue eux ils connaissent pas
ça donc c'est vraiment bien et émotion
on les fait découvrir par leur faire
découvrir notre culture du goût
[Musique]
c'est vraiment merveilleux de pouvoir
créer un lien avec eux ses élèves malgré
la barrière de la langue en fait et j'ai
trouvé vraiment fluide et il n'y a pas
de gêne et alors que pourtant plus
connais pas on n'a pas la même culture
n'a pas la même religion n'a pas la même
langue et j'ai trouvé ça incroyable on
rentre tout de suite dans un dans un
cercle un peu à peu intime parce que
c'est quand même montré ses dessins
danser c'est quelque chose d'assez
sécurisant
[Musique]
en couleurs
c'est une façon aussi de se dénigrer
peut-être bien de se mettre à l'aise
et puis ça se transporte en apportant la
musique même si on comprend pas la
langue il ya le rythme le sont
l'instrument surtout aussi qui fait que
ça se lâche les gens se lâchent a pas de
la rigueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant à l'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui dégoûte
c'est vraiment bien c'est très agréable
cette première rencontre est très
intéressante
c'est tellement enrichissant pour les
élèves de tous les niveaux c'est
vraiment bien
[Applaudissements]
ce que je pense du groupe
c'est que c'est vraiment agréable
je me sens
vous êtes très divertissant et c'est
vraiment bien aussi on apprécie beaucoup
vos danses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui